so yesterday we had a couple of things
coming out from the more high level
discussions about
stability or controllability for causal
relationship and i think you guys all do
more positive things here
and actionability context
i just want to see how you guys see
your work relate to this more high level
themes
this
stability concern
oh context concern
or do you have to
make some variables i saw a little bit
in my college talk like you want more
integral features
do you have multiple choices support
clarity so just
kind of get you guys away from them all
on detailed
very mechanistic models to this high
level issues
so
let me see if i understood the question
because the audio is a little bit uh
hidden
so basically you're asking if uh
if there are higher uh more coarse gray
in the
uh approaches that we
pursue rather than looking at just as
models that describe atomic interactions
and uh processes or
um yeah so yeah are there higher level
things you think it's more general than
your particular problem
that you just very deep into the physics
and chemistry and just go there oh
information learning in general besides
the message would that be helpful
i i think that to me the the the general
issue that i think i i feel very
strongly is that
in in fields that have been doing a lot
of computation
uh in a certain sense we have
we already have you know a
computational uh pipeline to get an
answer
so
i think that
personally i feel very strongly the need
to
justify myself for using machine
learning instead
because it's not like
uh
you know it's not it's a little bit
different from applying machine learning
directly to physical reality that is
by construction
um
there is also an element for instance of
noise and imperfection in the data and
you don't necessarily know what you're
looking at a lot of what i am doing
i know exactly what the answer should be
uh
and so i need to agree with you
somebody
who work in similar areas actually you
have exact
agreement on what's interpretable what
principles you should bring in like you
have fall additivity locality
and symmetry so there's a good agreement
on what interval means
so from this is a very specific and
somehow narrow uh
application of machine learning to my
field then you have more uh
[Music]
you know more end-to-end chemical models
where you really try to predict
uh will this molecule be toxic will this
molecule
work as a drug cure x
so
these are questions that i think
benefit less from
from incorporating
very strictly uh physical principles
into the model because the it's it's
very
similar to
to natural language processing where
actually incorporating
grammar
doesn't necessarily help you a lot
because there is so much
new ones there are so much so many
exceptions
that the rules don't help that much so i
i think that that would
may but even in that case i would say
that probably
some very very basic ideas such as
symmetry or locality
are
very deeply built so so you know you
might formulate the whole thing in a
different way less explicit you might
formulate the locality
uh
without explicitly setting a cutoff
distance in in
the expansion of the descriptors
but then locality
might take the form of a graph
algorithm that you truncate after just a
few iterations
thank you yeah david thank you so so i i
think i agree with what mick kelly has
said in terms of the
sorts of representation problems he's
working with
i think there's a little bit more
discussion in the kinds of problems i
was presenting
at some level
the goal of this line of research is to
have some event that occurs and be able
to tell a story about how it happens
so in that auto ionization event i want
to understand with some language
you know how you know what are the
fluctuations that are important for that
water to fall apart
and there there's a little bit more
ambiguity about what is the right way to
talk about that problem
you know should i
think about you know that kind of
there's a traditional
view in chemistry to think about a
configuration this is a configuration
that's really important this is if i get
there then i'll know that i'll just fall
downhill one way or the other
there's
a different kind of school of thought
where
i feel more comfortable with which is
more this is the typical trajectory that
the system has to
go through so it's a sequence of
snapshots
and i think
one thing that at least for me has
been useful in
learning more about the ml techniques is
how to sharpen that statement so
the
optimal force that we find to guide
these
dynamics
it was in kind of funneling down to find
that optimal that you find that there is
a quantity it's a bit of an abstract
quantity this
uh solution to the formograph equation
that is exactly kind of an ideal values
reaction coordinate there is an ideal
way to think about the reaction
occurring in a deterministic way that
abstracts always a noise that's
surrounding orthogonal directions
so in some cases
that force concentrates on a
configuration so the
traditional chemistry view where there's
one snapshot which is important it does
kind of get worn out in other cases you
see that there's a broad distribution of
paths that take you to the system so
this introductory picture becomes
important
but it's in kind of going through the
mechanics of this viewing it as an
optimization problem that you've got
these kind of more qualitative
statements can be shown
so
memorizing that rephrasing that you
actually the machine learning helps you
to do better science oh
yeah yeah it sharpened this question i
think it made
i mean i don't know that this is a
solved problem there are probably people
who disagree with me
in my view this points is a very clear
function that you know if you can find
the solution to you've solved the
problem
[Music]
so so do you
i'm not sure i fully understand
the topic looks very interesting but i
didn't follow through but
i i wonder
when you oh mckelly you provide some
kind of
interpretation sometimes of explanation
of how this very event happened
is it an interpretation of your
mathematical model of the physical world
or is it an interpretation of the
physical world itself
so
so i i can't speak for michelle but for
me it's always a a interpretation of the
physical model that i'm working within
so i have an overlying construct a way
of talking about forces that i think is
reasonable that's a good proxy for the
real physical world but i only ever feel
confident making statements or
interpretations within that confine
i i think that this touches upon a
little bit this question of
uh of the fact that we
you know we are very confident
because we have a ground truth so the
everything that we rely on our physical
model this is something that we can
really trust
within the limits of the physical model
then how this physical model is a good
model of the physical reality
uh it's
it's kind of tricky and something which
i think is a very interesting research
direction
is uh
using uh um
sort of using machine learning as a
bridge between
the physical models
and the experimental uh observations
because you can you know this is
something that people already did before
calling it machine learning so
like maximum entropy uh corrections
to
where you say okay i have uh for
instance a very simple example i have a
pair a
per correlation function that i derive
from
from a scattering experiment
i do my simulations based on a physical
model of the interactions
and the percolation function is
different
so
i can modify the interaction potential
in the most
minimally invasive way
to get a perfect match with the
experimental observation
so i i think that
machine learning
in principle could give a much more
flexible and generally applicable
uh
route to
incorporate corrections to physics-based
models
where basically machine learning brings
you the last mile you have
and i think that's very powerful because
then
uh you you you you can hope if you do
this smartly to then be also able to use
the model to make predictions on
something entirely different for which
perhaps doing experiments is very
difficult
so it's a crude analogy analogy can i
think of it as
bridging between a prior and a posterior
i mean your model is some prior of the
world then you have the posterior from
the experiment and you are trying to
move the prior in the direction of that
empirical data yeah and i i think that
actually maximum entropy
schemes can be formulated pretty
literally as a bayesian correction
yeah yeah shortly that's something
that's actually happening
let me follow up on that like suppose
you
can you imagine for david
different kind of translation
probability which is not physics based
but somehow
get you even better at getting the rare
events and later you can make it
interpretable so start from agnostic
just you have an important sampling
problem
can you imagine that happening or just
eventually have to bring back to physics
anyways
so so maybe maybe this touches on
kind of value questions like we talked
about yesterday
so
it is certainly the case that before
in the procedure i was talking about
gets optimized it's very easy to
actually see the transition occur i
could put an enormous force on the
system and drive it in some direction i
want to see but that doesn't tell me
anything about the underlying system i'm
interested in so if i value
not just seeing
something going from a to b but the
route in which it takes being close to
how it would naturally happen then i
have to put that extra constraint and
the regularization from the kl
divergence on it well is that a valuable
exercise i just want to go there because
i want the speed and then i do
distillation and get something oh
absolutely you know in the so
you know that's in practice
this is very specific but in practice
that's how we actually do the training
we just
add a force that is very unphysical just
to get a couple signals that we can then
start to train on we would never be able
to even start this procedure if we
couldn't do that
any questions from the audience yes
there's one thanks
so
in applications
in science it seems to me that the
problem with interpretability is is
often that you cannot interpret the
result
and
in
both lectures i it seems to me that this
problem somehow doesn't come up so
discuss the importance of having
interpretable features and then
both of you did not seem to have problem
with interpreting the results so is that
correct or i i think that's correct
because we're both starting in a similar
place which is not necessarily where
everybody starts
so we start with a physical model and
we're trying to use machine learning to
solve physically posed problems
as opposed to for example
another you know very
often employed
machine learning tool in chemistry right
now is
to just
take data and analyze it to try to find
leads for chemicals
to essentially do
plus you know very advanced kind of
clustering to borrow down into specific
sorts of
functional groups on molecules to find
which ones are going to be efficacious
and drug discovery that is just a pure
data problem and
the
output you get then is not very
interpretable because you don't have the
kind of guide rails that we've talked
about having a physically posed problem
that we're trying to solve
i don't know if you have anything to add
that mckelly
i would say you know i i agree that
there is really and
as i mentioned uh
there is also this question when
when you're using machine learning as a
surrogate for uh
for a physical model there is also this
lingering question of
do you really need to throw away
everything about the physical model or
there is something which is worth
salvaging and i think it's a little bit
of um
it's a trade-off
i mostly regard
machine learning as a shortcut to get
there faster
and
this can be uh you know
this is not diminishing the impact that
is having on our field it's really
something that can
the the kind of things that require the
uh to occupy a major supercomputer for
three months so now you can run on a
laptop so it's really
a game changer
but not necessarily for instance you
know say do you need
do you need for instance can you get
phase transitions from an explicit
sampling
or do you need to
cut out also the sampling part from the
physics-based model do you
uh
you do you
um
accelerate the sampling of the
transitions as
david does or you somehow directly
uh try to predict just from knowledge of
the
reactants and the product
you try to predict just out of this true
a possible
reaction pathway
and
i think that ultimately
given that as david says we are moving
within the boundaries of a physics of a
physical model
it's really a question of
computational efficiency
and
trade-off between
transferability and interpretability of
models that are explicitly physics-based
and the flexibility and potentially
ultimate accuracy of models that are
machine learning based
we're coming
from the yeah so we have a question from
liang tao
which is what's the relationship between
stability and interpretability
[Music]
maybe stability means
we need to uh i need an interpreter for
the question
well maybe if i understand questions
yesterday yeah
if
the question is asking stability of data
perturbation
oh is that model preparation that's why
say stability is both
you have all these different
perturbations to the pipeline and i
would say that stability is a
prerequisite for interpretability
right so so that's my next one maybe i
can mix it in right so mikali was using
more uh
i would say first generation machine
learning algorithms right regression svm
and you went for deep learning
and there was also something early
question because the inductive biases of
machine learning algorithm
right suppose they both give you similar
kind of objective prediction whatever
error how do you
differentiate to know which
algorithm introduce the right inductive
bias
and that's related to
stability because there can be
many different algorithms that give you
similar objective
performance
how do you guys um
mitigate this tension
when you do your modeling
before you switch could you make your
thing work using more traditional
machine learning
vice versa maybe some small different
earnings will work for michaela as well
he just didn't try
yeah i mean
sorts of things that i'm doing
the inter the
the details of the representation
i think are less important so you know
you know the thing sorts of things that
i'm doing
the only difference between deep
learning and more traditional ones is
just a functional representation if
we're using a sensor network or if we're
using
you know
gaussian gaussian process or something
and because we've again we're working
within a physical model
we know at the end of the day that all
of those things sum up to just be a
force so i know how to interpret a force
it's a drift
uh
the
decomposing it then
you know
because the forces are
are summed in simple ways we can do that
we can prune things so we can say
did i really need
five hidden layers or can i prune this
to be smaller and i can do that because
i can
the
cost function is just some
sum over all the added forces so i i
have a variational statement i know how
that variational
optimum degrades as i start pruning some
of the
features in the representation
maybe that's very specific to the sorts
of things i'm doing
so multiple uh deep learning that will
work for you it doesn't really matter
yeah i mean it depends a lot on the
problem some problems need the
expressibility of the
you know a tensor network and that
depends on just kind of how chaotic the
dynamics are but i can make those sorts
of statements because at the end of the
day i know
what all of those things are summed into
it's just a force
i can have simple measures of the the
evolution of the system and i know
causally how those forces are acting to
change that
space exploration
so in my experiences so usually my
thought process works like this so
very often when you use a linear uh
really not even a kernel method just
good old linear regression
very often you can
explicitly
show the link between the
representation that you're using
and
the expressive power of
the resulting model so for instance uh
you know
for these uh density correlation
features linear models correspond
to body ordered expansions of the target
property uh for the formulation that we
use of long-range descriptors a linear
model corresponds to a multiple
expansion of the electrostatics
literally you know it's basically the
same thing you're just
formulating it using the computational
tools of machine learning but you are
really doing the same thing
and then my thought process is that
after you have
built a model that is interpretable
because the linear form allows you to
analytically show what actually you're
doing
then you can use your features
into a new linear model
that can bring in
higher order correlations and less
predictable stuff but at least you know
what is the uh
you know
what is the simple uh
limit you would revert to if you went uh
you if you just stayed linear now
very often particularly in the data poor
region
uh linear models do just fine
and actually an aspect which i think
would be very interesting to think about
is that
if you go from using
simulations where you can afford to
generate tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of training points
to experiments
we have a paper recently where we try to
classify
zeolites
between
uh synthesizable and not synthesizable
now there are 250 zeolites that have
ever been made so good luck using a deep
i mean i think that if somebody used a
fancy deep neural network
on a data set of 250 data points
the only reaction can be laughter
because it doesn't make any sense you
you don't have enough
uh
you know you don't have enough
data to actually exploit that all that
flexibility
so
but but i think that you know
there will be certain space for more
sophisticated models so
as
we move into
more data rich applications i mean i
think that alpha fold is a is a nice
example where the amount of data that
had been accumulated that was sufficient
to apply if
it's not actually an extraordinarily
sophisticated model there is a lot of
physical ideas built into
it but it is definitely more the linear
regression
thank you
[Music]
our question is um david in your talk so
you're acting as theoretical model where
you
[Music]
your action space is sort of like
enormous compared to what
like anyone in any actual
real world experiment would get to
manipulate right
and it's to get to some
fundamental understanding of what does
it take to cause certain kinds of
transitions i'm not
just trying to confirm my understanding
um so i imagine now like uh if any you
know
like lowly experimenters
you know uh closer to the uh earth now
want to
like
take some insight from this and go out
and try to
i i want to make sure i even understand
how this situated in the like scope of
things that people adjacent to you do i
you know
one hope might be that someone would get
some insight from this now they would
know how to go out and affect the world
and
so it seems like there's a
sort of maybe like very clear
interpretive step here of like going
from
oh if i can choose from every single
force that's applied at every single
point in time to every single object in
this complex system and i have this
you know massive possibly like
continuous you know like
object and and and you could say you
know you could produce like the optimum
and just say like here's the thing you
should do like from this initial
computer is the exact set of things that
is the
optimal set of forces in this
wildly large action space that you don't
actually have access to
um
but what you might hope to get is
something
um a kind of cruder
sort of like qualitative understanding
that someone could
like a variety of stakeholders who are
trying you know within their limited
powers to actually influence actual
systems to do certain foldings to do
um
could actually get some sort of insight
from so i guess
like is is that like how do you think of
that interpretive step and like i mean
even when you present the findings the
end of the day like
how do you try to distill the like
gestalt from the just the
like here's the solution
yeah no that that's a very important
step you know because it doesn't serve
so there's utility in getting this
optimal force that lets me see the
trajectories but i can't
i'm not going to try to
put a plot of that
three-in-dimensional
force on a slide i'm not going to hand
that to somebody and say this is
understanding so what one tries to do
then is to project that into
you know the most important
contributions along that high
dimensional space so that helps you kind
of tell the story of if this is what has
to happen it's this
so it might not be
an individual molecule has to jiggle in
just this one way but there might be a
collective fluctuation that has to
happen that can be easier to describe so
just to give you something concrete in
the case of a water molecule falling
apart
it's true that the optimal force acts on
all the particles and it's kind of
complicated
but a very
high a very responsible projection in
the variational sense of responsible you
don't lose a lot in the cost function
of projecting that force down into
a single coordinate that works really
well is just what is the electric field
that the solution
gives to that one water molecule when i
essentially put a huge voltage across it
that's what has to happen for it to fall
apart
so then that's a simple story that i
could say in words that doesn't require
the
three-in-dimensional object that
that i can use to then study that
problem but i would have needed to do
that step first
in order to then take the optimal one
and project down and see which one is
the
simplest
physical statement i can make
um
hi thanks for the talk i have a
follow-up question to what sectors said
what if we uh try to
model the physical action space that an
experimenter had access to
would and try to find the optimal on
that like are there like do you think
that would be possible would that be an
advantage to
finding some apps might i'd say more
abstract optimal and then projecting or
um have you thought about that so so
yes we think about it all the time in
fact usually we start that way
we we usually actually start with how
simple can we get and then only go to
the deep nets when we have to right
and we also do work with
experimentalists that are pulling so we
can try to optimize a protocol in an
incomplete control sense where you only
have one or two ways you can manipulate
the system so both have huge
advantages one is just a computational
advantage if there's a simpler object
that you have to evaluate then that's
nice it speeds up the computation um
and the
you know being able to work with the
experimentalists actually say this is
what you you know if you could just pull
on one direction maybe this is the best
direction or this is the speed at which
you should vary things
that's very useful and actually works
quite well i mean
in
in lots of problems there is a
lots of physical problems there is a
condensation onto a couple collective
coordinates that the optimal force
falls into we don't really understand
why that
seems to happen so often as it does
and so that's a kind of
current avenue of a lot of the thinking
in my group is you know why is this
condensation so present even though we
know formally the solution exists in the
mini body space
so i have a question that connecting to
if i understand correctly right there
are two
i think mikali talk about emerging
behavior through temperature change and
if i understand you'll talk correctly
that this one molecule can change has
kind of like phase transition behavior
in your system is that right like this
is chemical emerging behavior and
there's so phase transition is very holy
word in chemistry it means actually very
special but there are dynamical
bifurcations
oh actually that's the right way that
two different things could happen phase
transitions usually mean something very
singular if i make the system infinite i
have a sharp change but emergent
behavior then i mean like yeah so is
that right that there's like local
behavior
can
have this emerging behavior absolutely
yeah and then the other one are there is
a duality between the two in some sense
like that's a big big area of open
questions you know how do you think
about so they're
you know if you go over to the physics
department here there are people for a
long time who've thought about dynamical
systems that have bifurcations in them
you know when can you draw analogies
between
few molecule dynamical systems that
exhibit such things and phase
transitions sometimes there are
correspondences and sometimes there's
not
and one would like to understand kind of
the higher order structure is to
how to classify those things
that's called bifurcation yeah and
that's different from the temperature
change for the
well the temperature change is uh so
there what is true is that
there is a partition sum either in
trajectory space or configuration space
that has
holes in it and dynamically that's a
pole that gives your eyes to different
dynamical behavior a phase transition is
a pole in the configurational partition
so as i change the weights with the
temperature i condense on one set of
states or the other
i think
thank you
we have a question from the ether
[Music]
so this is from
mohammed he says
a bit more general question
suppose your model is a mean field
theoretic high dimensional approximation
etc to start with how do you go about
using machine learning or deep learning
in particular
approaches to interpret or delineate or
analyze the behavior of your model
sorry for the vagueness of the question
smiley face
winky face um
[Music]
kelly do you have an answer to that
i don't know i i think that
you know this hinge is a little bit uh
on i don't know how how the discussion
yesterday went yeah i was on a on a
train and they couldn't connect
but i think that hinges a little bit on
the issue of what we really mean by
interpretability i i'm a little bit
uncomfortable with the
because it's a concept that is very
closely tied to
you know to questions on how our brain
functions
when when you say interpret ebola you
kind of
and and also similar questions about you
know how can you help experimentalists
uh sort of uh
could be translated into how do you
extract some simple rule of thumb
uh that a human can use
i think that there is
i mean it's an interesting question to
ask oneself but at the end of the day i
think that the
uh
another interesting question is you know
do we need this if we can get a machine
to
tell us what is the material that you
have to make and how to do it
you know both
theorists and experimentalists can go
home
so we might be a little bit afraid of
this prospect but
in a certain sense
what is it that makes us so and i am the
first one of being very keen on being
able to interpret what i'm doing
but sometimes i ask myself if i just
feel threatened
by the prospect of something that can do
my job
uh in a way that i don't understand
maybe i can so one way that i i
interpret that question
is the distinction between kind of
bottom-up approaches and top-down
approaches you know one way to view i
think what that question is asking so if
i start with a
a very core screen a mean field model
how do i learn maybe the physics that
i'm missing
i think that that's hard i have no idea
how to do that i mean i think
that that is a just intrinsically hard
problem because there's information that
you don't know that you have to inject
somehow and most of i think what i've
talked about and what mckelly's talked
about are kind of bottom-up approaches
we know
ground truth we know what the physical
laws are and we try to strip away as
much of the details we can and there we
know
the information we're losing so we could
always kind of bring it back but if
you're going
top down
you need to know how to learn new
information i don't know how to do that
so so on this trend of top down versus
bottom up
one of i think
big challenges for us i mean it's only
loosely related to what you're doing but
in the high level it's connected this
trying to understand
society trying to stand how come a
society suddenly elects a dictator how
come
a
economic
bubble bursts
these are kind of
rare events
that are affected by many many small
particles the individuals
and in they have some kind of
similarities to the type of things that
you're talking about
and
following the the last question i mean
we don't really understand
the dynamics of a
specific person specific participant in
the society
and we also have very crude
understanding of the
high level of the of the
uh overall behavior but it's somewhere
in between and i was wondering if you
can say something about what is missing
to be able to apply similar approaches
to to societal issues
[Music]
so you know this is a bias that i have
but you know from
you know the kind of way one approaches
problems with statistical mechanics is
that you have a model of the fine grain
and then you try to understand how
things emerge from it
and you know one thing that serves us
very well is a lot of times
the higher level behavior the emergent
behavior depends weekly on the details
of the model so even though the model's
not right
it has something
that's correct
so that this thing can emerge
and
you know how you come up with that
ground model then is hard you know that
is
what i don't know how to automate you
know i don't know how to learn it's
something that you kind of get a vague
sense for when you see what other models
look like and what they're able doing
you kind of have the guide rails of
theories that tell you you know what are
the necessary conditions for certain
kinds of emergent behavior to occur
but i mean i think that there are
you know there those kinds of ideas
in society i mean
people like jeffrey west
have
notions of scaling laws that can explain
some emergent behaviors without knowing
too much about the underlying details of
how a mod you know a person
moves through a city
but you know
how they
arrived at that initial model from which
the higher level structure emerges i
don't know
how that is automated or how that is
learned
mikhail do you want to add to that
i don't know this sounds a little like
psycho history right so you want to
build uh it's i i think that i i agree
with david that
the
i mean in a certain sense this is a very
similar to the thought process of
statistical mechanics so you have
uh particles that you can't model very
accurately
but you build a model that captures the
essence of what's going on and then more
often than not this gives you very
robust
and i mean start stable right as
we were saying this link between
stability and interpretability a lot of
statistical mechanical models are very
stable to perturbations of the of the
actual model now why
a
more predictive theory of society has
not
arised from a similar i i mean i'm not
aware of uh you know established and the
sort of uh
theory of society that is capable of
quantitative predictions
i don't know i i know a few sociologists
and i think that one of the big issues
is that it's
even harder to measure you know to
really define
measurable quantities that you can
objectively associate with the behavior
of society so i think that this is
something that this qualitative aspect
personally i feel that i'm not really
even equipped to think about
uh quest questions that that cannot be
formulated into you know i have a
quantity that i measure and then i
predict how this quantity will evolve in
time
you know people try to measure the level
of democracy
but it's
it's in itself very far from being
universally accepted how you measure the
level of democracy so i think that there
is this additional aspect
which makes it particularly hard the
the sort of catastrophic uh
behavior the sort of um
avalanche
behavior that happens when a democracy
collapses for instance
and the fact that it's even harder to
say you know is the us more democratic
now than it was uh uh
under mixed nixon
i don't know how to quantify that
ask again in a few weeks
yeah
well we have about 15 minutes maybe i
can encourage some of the younger
members of the audience
we have a small cozy group if we can get
some of the younger people to speak up
anybody want to take a shot
um
i guess
getting into some of some of the
you nitty-gritty different um different
machine learning techniques um and
clustering as well have you have you
looked at um like like like a technique
such as uh dictionary learning where you
can where you can try to make
predictions and and at the end of the
day you might have like like like an
understanding of the of the underlying
uh structure of the of the very high
dimensional and i get and it seems like
sparse sparse um
phenomenon that you have that you have
going on um that's that's that's part
part one of my question no that you
i i don't know what dictionary learning
that's what is dictionary learning
okay sorry maybe michelle
he knows more of these things than i do
no i don't know what is dictionary
either so you can just we can discuss
all this goes offline part
part two like the the the models that
you that you showed it was was kind of
like you know i'm not i'm not a
physicist it was kind of like like
like foreign verification
do you test like
i i presume you you test like which
which model your your data fit fits and
which which one you reject it rejects
can you maybe elaborate on that on like
how many on
typical on a typical day or typical week
how many models you go you go through
and how many you you reject or are you
are you like right the f the first time
or well
never
um i could so so for me there's kind of
two levels of model verification there's
the model verification within the
physical model that we're working with
so we're trying to extract
abstract you know some sort of quantity
within that model and we can ask how
well are we abstracting that model so
concretely this might be the rate of
some rare event i have a physical model
where the
particles interact i want to
find out a way of extracting rate and
yeah there's a number of different ways
i could do that and so i have to ask how
well am i doing that
and so you know that that
we spend a lot of our time doing
um
you know it's
because we have variational principles
that kind of act as guide rules we kind
of know when we've done better we don't
usually know
what the ground truth is
and so we only know that if we keep
adding features that we're not getting
better so maybe we can hope that that's
right we have some
kind of indirect sanity checks that lets
us test for robustness and things but
that's about as well as we can do
but a very important kind of higher
level
validation is
is this actual reality you know
we have a model of the physical world is
that actually what someone would go
measure
and so that's done much
less frequently but is is important that
requires you know going across the hall
and talking to my experimental
colleagues to say i really think i know
this number how could we dream up an
experiment to measure it or are there
things that are correlated with that
number that might be easier to measure
that we can also predict
uh
and that's kind of the
usually the end of the projects where we
think we really know what's going on
microscopically but we want to make sure
that the underlying model we're using is
reasonable
something that we something that we do a
lot that perhaps goes a little bit in
this direction
is
uh
you know isn't uncertainty
quantification so it's not really it's
not so much uh choosing between models
but
making sure that you can
uh
make a statement on the reliability of a
model
this is something which i think is very
useful and should be done
more uh consistently in
in
machine learning applications in which
you have a quantitative answer putting a
narrow bar on the prediction
is something which is picking up a lot
of steam and they think that it will
become
more and more frequent and that
implicitly uh if you have multiple
models so you can and you can estimate
the uncertainty then this gives you an
objective way of picking between
different models
and not necessarily you know you might
even choose to use a different model for
different parts
of
um of the
of the of the problem space so you know
you might you might have one part that
you have a very precise
answer but that model is very unstable
and then you have
a less precise but more robust model
that you use when you're really
uh into a more speculative region
thank you
any other question you want to add oh no
but he had a question
um
so i i i mean i'm intrigued by what
you're saying about
reliability or confidence or trust in a
model but
i don't know how to define those things
and it sounds implicitly like you define
them as the amount of stability of the
amount versus the amount of variability
but it's not necessarily how reliable
the or or how correct a model a measure
of correctness or something
so something that we do that works very
well
and is very easy to apply
is uh
committee
models committees basically you generate
multiple models
what we do usually is we just
sub sample the training set
and then
you generate multiple predictions and
this is basically a measure of stability
so how much do your prediction depend on
a perturbation of the model
and these you can calibrate and they
actually become a pretty decent
estimates
of how accurate is your model
and
i i don't know i like this approach a
lot because it makes very easy also to
propagate uncertainty you make your
predictions
you get 10
you use them to do whatever you want to
do
and at the end of the day
this propagates uncertainty in a way
that you know it's imperfect but it's
uh it's it's simple and quite reliable
so this speaks to our
or what one of several lively debates
during our extended coffee breaks but
um
whenever you talk about uncertainty
i think it also applies to notions of
stability and and notions of robustness
there's
always
uh
somewhere whether it's whether it's
stated explicitly or not there's there's
a with respect to what
and um
i'm curious you know in your domain what
the the sort of the whats are but you
know for example
um
let's take stability for example there's
stability in
that if i subsample my training data
that you know i have different finite
samples that are from the same exact
data set
i'll get out a similar model there's
stability in the sense that
my model
whatever i think i'm getting out
proports describe uh a general i think
i'm describing
falling objects not just apples that
came from this one tree and so my data
set is only all the apples that fell
from the street but you know i went out
and i measured baseballs that fell from
whatever so there's a different
stability which is
uh
not one that is confined to a very
specific you know
uh just different iid samples from the
same data generating crossbar but but
more broadly the the physical phenomena
that i think i'm
right molly
random initialization of your system
right sure
so um
you know i think saying when it comes to
uncertainties like how
how confident am i in
uh
how things would change right if i
change the random seed if i change the
sample if i change something else in the
system so i guess like in terms of those
those with respect to x like what are
the x's that matter
uh for you and that you tend to focus on
yeah
kelly maybe i can start so
i mean i think one broad statement that
simplifies my life a lot
is that the systems that we're
interested in physical systems have a
lot of self-averaging behavior
self-averaging behavior so if i take a
set of molecules they have a finite
correlation length i make the box two
times bigger
i essentially get the same sort of
statistics because
they're not correlated over that whole
domain so i have self averaging in space
they're also typically
finite correlated in time so they're not
iid random variables but the correlation
times are small
so i could alternatively to just make
boxes bigger
reinitializing i could just run longer
and it will erg here
the systems that we're interested in
almost always ergotic so long enough it
will revisit different states
that means that
randomizing things is made simple
because i have lots of choices that
almost always are
the same right essentially gives me the
same way of generating new data
you know one has to check that those
assumptions are true there are
pathological cases that one always has
to be aware of
but
you know typically
that's actually what you do is you
actually ask if i compare to
generating with a new initial condition
or just running it twice as long do i
get the same result if i
oh yeah the random seed should almost
never matter because systems are so
chaotic that initial conditions are lost
almost instantaneously
but still one tests that that's actually
true
um
so yeah so i mean those are the i mean
we do those sorts of things but usually
they're all self-averaging so it doesn't
matter
do you want to add
i i mean for
us
so
at least when building these uh
models committee models
uh what we care about at the end is
being able to predict the actual error
of our prediction
uh so at that point
what you perturb your model
uh relative to
uh
it's not so important as i mean you can
basically assess this
uh by
uh choosing the perturbation that allows
you to predict more
reliably the accuracy of your model
and
something that
also uh i think relates to these
is uh basically that if
um
you know
so in terms of using a very uh
restricted data set uh
at least which is iad we never use the
training sets that are uh iid i think
that most of the time the
objective is to get a data set which is
as diverse as possible
and actually these uh uncertainty
estimates
can also help you uh
basically enrich your training set so
there is a lot of active learning that
goes on
so you don't need your uncertainty
estimate to be
uber precise you just need it to tell
you oh look you know these
now right now this model is really
returning garbage so you need to extend
the training to also include
the baseballs and not just the airports
that are falling from this specific tree
and uh so in a certain sense i think
that this robustness is something that
can also be adapted dynamically
if you have a well-defined
objective
which in my opinion is to be able to
predict if you can trust your results or
not
thank you i think this is a very
interesting
discussion i have thought a lot about
that maybe i just jumped into
about this reference set right i think
we actually have viewed some uh
frameworks with the pcs framework try to
take into account these different
randomized starting points to different
algorithms think about what are the
possible answers you could generate in
the whole pipeline
and think of more like a discrete
universe of potential data
and all answers and then use that as a
reference
and then you make a document to argue
why this potential data or potential
answers are legitimate
you write a lot on both the narrative
and also understanding the process
and saying that
if your id assumption the bootstrap idea
is really
we could pretend or can believe the
bootstrap sample is as if another new
data set right you make that argument
under the id assumption and you have
asymptotics to verify that
but that's kind of the idea is unifying
what xiao was saying about random
starting point you have different
algorithms and you can put that in two
just from the answer point of view
and you have unification relating to
this
how called potential answers
beyond the classical statistical
framework
but well thank you both for two
excellent talks and lovely discussions
and all the great questions from the
audience and
we'll resume at 3 p.m i hope you can go
to sleep me callie thank you for staying
up yeah it's not so late oh it's not too
late no no it's not past nine that's
fine okay
now you can have another three hours
thanks
nice seeing you yeah
thank you
oh
a union
global change with the microscope